So, you want to ride the New York City subway?
Great idea!
It's the preferred way for locals to get around.
But with 468 subway stations and 24 separate lines,...
...you'll need to know a few things first.
The New York City subway lines are organized by letter, number, and color.
Know which direction you are going.
Some stations like Union Square and Times Square have an entrance that leads to all lines.
But some smaller entrances are one-way: uptown or downtown.
Make sure you know you're going in the right direction.
A standard ride on the subway is 2.50 for a single ride MetroCard.
As long as you stay underground, you can ride numerous lines on the same card...
...and even transfer to a bus for no additional fee.
If you're in New York for a week, it pays to buy the weekly pass.
There's only one way to swipe the card:...
...with the black stripe facing towards you and down.